the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I want to continue our discourse about
musicals especially as a way of trying
to lead into the two remarkable in many
ways landmark films were going to
juxtapose this evening remember that our
plan here is to juxtapose one film a
classic instance even a culminating
instance of the studio era and of the
tradition of the musical in the studio
era against another kind of musical that
appears after the advent of television
and after the studio system has begun to
break apart in and especially after the
the the fundamental transformation that
the audience underwent migrating from an
habitual a regular a weekly relationship
to Hollywood films to essentially a
blockbuster relationship in which they
would attend the movies the vast
majority of Americans would attend the
movies only once or twice a year and if
you think about the implications of that
that fact alone will explain how
profoundly the movie industry was
transformed incidentally I should
mention to you that this is still not an
idea that has been fully understood by
what I'll call traditional film
historians who are so locked into an
idea that film must resemble the kind of
thing that ice that I learned that I
watched when I grew up as a boy or as a
as well as a young as a young girl and
now that a tradition of scholarship has
talked about that is to say those films
that never were shown on television or
never made for television it causes a
problem because what these ëthey
scholars tend to do is they ignore the
social context within which the function
of the movies began to be transformed
partly there was a kind of hostility on
the on the part of many older film
scholars toward the notion that
television might be a worthy
place to look for a valuable cinematic
narrative and it took a long time before
the film scholars the film scholarly the
community of film scholars even a part
of it was ready to acknowledge that
television was also an environment in
which in which cinema what we might call
cinema audio-visual narrative could be
looked at taken seriously and so forth
and of course today it's taken for
granted by many commentators many of
them no longer even with a cultural
memory of the studio era that what goes
on on television that shows like
breaking bad or The Sopranos are the
supreme forms of audio-visual
entertainment in our society
this too is a little over simpler is
radically oversimplified and I will
return to these questions a bit later
when we when I when we talk when I talk
about the westerns in and about and
about film in the 70s in two weeks I
want to continue our discourse about
about the musical then first by giving
you a very brief perspective drawn from
the film scholar Leo Brody
whose essay the aesthetics of connection
is required reading I think for this
week in any case for this week or next
week and he talks in that essay among
other things very richly about the
musical and about ways of thinking about
the musical and I'm I'm borrowing from
an argument he makes in that in that
remarkable essay he makes a distinction
in that essay or abour a series of
comparisons between Astaire and Kelly
the two great male leads we associate
with the American film musical and he
sees them very helpfully as contrasting
figures illustrating what we might call
contrasting elements or contrasting
tendencies within the musical form think
if you think about a stair and you saw
him in one of his classic performances
at the end of our last lecture in that
sequence cheek to cheek if you think
about a stair in this way you can get
from that sequence you can get something
of what we Brody had in mind he talks
about he reminds us that a stair often
dances almost always dances it and this
is a partially a part
an exception and the film you saw
tonight only a partial one but but
almost always we see as they are dancing
in places that seem intended for
performance they say we won't see a
Astaire dancing in the middle of a
cornfield or dancing up the side of the
Empire State Building as Frank Sinatra
and Gene Kelly do in a in a musical it's
called on the town now and it's one it's
one of the wonderful MGM musicals Kelly
and Sinatra are dancing in spaces that
are inappropriate for dance but almost
all of Astaire's dances take place
either in literal performance spaces or
in public environments that seem as if
they're quasi staged or or dance
environments in other words these he
dances in spaces that we expect for
dance and and he doesn't violate those
spaces in some way he often in his films
plays either a professional dancer or a
professional performer of some kind so
when he segues into his performances
there's a kind of natural connection
he's almost always very fancily dressed
and as you saw in tonight's sequence
sometimes very often dancing in the tux
and Tails but in any case in formal
dress of some kind so he dances in
spaces appropriate for dance dressed up
in a kind of in a kind of formal way
play in often playing a professional
dancer or performer but there's an
immense Grace and energy in his in his
dancing he's one of the great dancers in
him in as many would say the greatest
dancer who ever performed in American
movies and one way to talk about what
the attractions of what he's doing is we
can say that what he embodies is a is
the principle of grace under constraint
like a great baseball pitcher look a lot
of people can throw the ball 97 miles an
hour but only a very small number of
people of pitchers who make a lot of
money can throw a ball 97 miles an hour
and control where it goes and we can say
that that kind of athletic power to them
a lot of athletics involves this where
you're where you're trying to control
tremendous physical energy and the
physical energy has to become
strained in certain ways and part of
what we admire about the expression of
that physical energy is how constrained
or graceful it could be it can become
there are many people who make who have
made analogies between Astaire's dancing
and what great basketball players do
with showing showing tremendous physical
energy but also a kind of gratefulness
on within the constraints that are
imposed upon them by the lines on the
court by the demands of the basket and
so by the claims of gravity when they
jump and so forth and I make allusion to
these non dance analogies because so so
many people seem to respond more fully
to those than to dance them itself even
though those of you who have danced or
our dancers or no serious dancers will
understand that dancers themselves are
much greater athletes than most athletes
and that and that there is a profound
form of athleticism of physical energy
Grace and physical control involved in
dance we've seen that in Astaire's
performances it's as if he stands for a
form of grace under constraint of
strength and power constrained but not
but not undermined by the by the rules
and boundaries within which it must
operate it's a form of classical art and
what we can say is that Kelly stands for
classicism
I'm sorry Astaire stands for the classic
for the clap for classicism and Gene
Kelly who is a kind of opposite in this
way in his dances stands for the
romantic right the classic and the
romantic tendencies or energies I'm
oversimplifying here as Brody does but
again it's a useful and illuminating
simplification because we see Kelly for
example mostly he doesn't play
professional performers or professional
dancers he almost he almost always wears
ordinary casual clothing open shirts
jeans he and this casualness of
appearance is matched by the fact that
the dances he engages and often take
place in spaces that are not appropriate
for dance are almost hostile to dance
and one of the deepest principles of
Kelly's performances of Kelly's dances
are there is this in a certain sense is
this contest between
exuberance and the and energy and the
constraints that surround him but unlike
unlike Astaire he does not reveal the
power and grace of his dance by
acknowledging the constraints and living
within them he had the energy of his
dance expresses itself in the moments
when he over goes boundaries when he
violates borders of various kinds and
there are numerous examples of this in
singin in the rain I'll give you that
I'll mention some of them in a little
while so so the contrast between Kelly
and Astaire in this way both and and
look in in both cases I've simplified
because they also resemble each other in
certain ways but these tendencies
distill quality the this argument to
stills qualities in them that clarify
certain energies or attentions that can
be said to be characteristic not only of
their to dance styles and the kinds of
movies these two stars are in but also
in the musical genre as a whole I'd like
to say a couple of things about each of
the two films we're going to see tonight
by but by way of framing some of the
most important issues for you to think
about and I think without trying to
anticipate too much and I have to get
these are very rich complex texts and 20
minutes of conversation no matter how
pointed can never do full justice to
them I don't intend to do full justice
to them but I want to suggest some ways
for you to think about aspects of these
films as you're viewing them and my hope
and expectation is that these
perspectives will energize an and live
in the film for you and who kill you in
two aspects of the film that you might
otherwise not see as deeply or might not
occur to you until you reflect it on the
film after the case one way to think
about singing in the rain then our
classic Holly our example of a Hollywood
musical a culminating instance of a
Hollywood musical is to recognize that
it belongs to a subcategory of musicals
to several subcategories of musicals one
of which I've already mentioned the
putting on the show the backstage story
but here the backstage story is the
story of a movie instead of a play but
it's the same basic the same basic
but it is also sometimes called a song
catalog movie because there are so many
songs in it and it's kind of a kind of
catalog or or an encyclopedic object in
an encyclopedia of film of new music and
of song and this is almost literally
true of singing in the rain Arthur freed
the the the executive producer of so
many of major films over 40 MGM musicals
between something like 1939 what was the
great musical in 1939 The Wizard of Oz
the first musical that is thought to be
a musical in color and think how
organically The Wizard of Oz uses color
Arthur freed was the executive producer
of that film from that point until
sometime in the 1960s he was the
executive producer or the supervisor of
something like 40-plus MGM musicals of
which singing in the rain is a classic
is a classic instance and so fread had
worked as a lyricist Arthur freed had
worked as a lyricist at MGM with nacio
herb Brown the songwriter
many years earlier and most of the songs
in singing in the rain 1952 had been
introduced in MGM musicals from 1929 on
so in a literal sense the film is a kind
of encyclopedia of older songs thus and
especially two key songs in the film
Broadway melody and you were meant for
me were both featured in that early and
and and signature musical that founding
musical that I mentioned this afternoon
the Broadway melody of 1929 so part of
the pleasure for older members of the
audience in 1952 would have been to hear
and see these numbers in the new
souped-up Arrangements that were created
for this film in such and in such artful
performances there's one song in the
film that my colleague Martin marks ma
RK s he sometimes teaches this course in
the spring he
a professor of music and he and he
sometimes and I encourage all of you to
consider taking it teaches us an
advanced course in the American Musical
it's a wonderfully interesting course
and he knows more about the musical I
think than almost any living human being
and I'm stealing from some of his
teaching notes here when I when I say
this is it
one song that Marty marks loves to talk
about isn't one quick it a minor song in
the film and I'm mentioning it because
you might miss it otherwise it's called
would you and it's a it's a song about
it it's a song that shows the process of
dubbing right and it's a it's a it's a
song that actually has a kind of plot
and historical function within the film
it comes near the end of the film and
when it was sung in this moment it was
all well it was already old fashioned in
its original day when it was first when
it was first written and sung and by
1952 it's much more outmoded professor
Marx tells us although it's a simple and
graceful waltz it uses an antiquated
diction for example and and there are
other signals that even the fact that
it's a waltz that show it to be kind of
old-fashioned in a way but in singing in
the rain this old-fashioned song is used
to telescope the process of recording
for films shot by shot watch how it
happens it's a very exciting moment
because and so what happens then is that
the old-fashioned song becomes the
cornerstone of the new technology of
sound recording watch how it happens in
the film and what this calls our
attention to is something is is is
something I've talked about earlier and
we'll return to in a moment the whole
the idea that in certain in the most
remarkable works of art we are surely
aware of the fact that we're in the
presence of what the literary critics
and the art critics sometimes call
organic form in which the form of the
text contributes to its meaning in which
form and content are married are hard to
say you can't really be separated that
the formal behavior of the text and acts
or embodies or articulates or dramatizes
what the film is about what the text
means I'll come back to this point in a
a minute with even more dramatic
examples I I hope so at an added point
about about this would useful just this
one sort of a minor sequence well I'm
mentioning this partly to show you how
deeply you could actually dig into
particular sequences and particular
songs in the film and find meaning
relevance and complexity there when
Debbie Reynolds who sings the song looks
point-blank at Gene Kelly as she sings
it she drives home the question of
whether he'll be brave enough to love
her right
so it even implicates it implicates
itself in the love story that's at the
heart of the film um her singing voice
we might know it ironically and
comically in this scene is actually
dubbed for this song and you'll
understand if you haven't seen the film
why that's a comic and ironic commentary
she had the wrong kind of voice was too
flat and nasal for this operetta like
number so they dubbed her voice so
there's a double irony because she's
playing a doubler when she sing when
she's singing this song and you might
compare the voice in good morning
another number the thing where Debbie
Reynolds is really singing and and you
can see the difference between the
between the two voices okay so so what
the point of all the point I've made at
the implicit point that I made in
talking about this one this one number
the would you song number it has to do
with what we might call a central
element or a feature of singing in the
ring it's profound
self-consciousness the profound way in
which in which it shows itself to be
aware of itself to be aware of itself as
a movie to be aware of itself as a
bearer of a traditions of singing of
dancing and performance and it's it that
makes it so it isn't simply an
encyclopedia of musical history it's
almost an encyclopedia of different
forms of almost all forms of performance
I don't want to go too far but there's
many many forms of performance are
incorporated in the in the films in the
films grasp in the films embrace alright
we get one way we can think of it as an
encyclopedic recapitulation of
the history of music of musicals and of
films in general that as you'll notice
when you look at the film there the
singing in the rain has begins by being
about the problem of trance of changing
a silent film into a sound film because
the silent the silent film has been made
just at that cusp moment when the
transition to sound is occurring in the
film in that sense is also a wonderful
sort of historical reprieves for members
of our for our course even though it
wasn't made for that purpose alas and
and so so in the film then we also get
an allusion to and a representation of
silent movies but not just any not just
some generic idea of silent movies a
very particular kind of swashbuckler
adventure film is dramatized there and
then later in a scene I mentioned
earlier today in the audition scene the
beautiful girl sequence in singing in
the rain where a megaphone suddenly
turns into a circle of dancers alluding
to the Busby Berkeley tradition we have
a very specific reference to another
kind of movie musical right so
juxtaposed against each other are two
different kinds of movies right there
and I've only mentioned a couple of
examples as you watch the film you'll
see dozens and dozens of instances in
which the film capacious Lee reaches
back to older forms of performance and
tries to incorporate them in some sense
into its own structure into its own
energies and there are many older
performance forms in the film their
forms of slipped slapstick and Keeton
Keeton like comedy especially in Donald
O'Connor's wonderful dance and song
sequence make them laugh there are
allusions and references and dramatized
scenes from vaudeville from jazz from
what we might call forms of love
melodrama all the way through the film
and so the whoa and I've hardly
exhausted that I haven't really
catalogued even remotely all the kinds
of performance spaces and performance
types that the film incorporates and
utilizes in the course of its length
nor have I even begun to list the number
of musical styles particular particular
songs
particular dance styles that are also
incorporated into the film but I've said
enough to suggest that the singing in
the rain has what might be called a
structural or a formal exuberance a kind
of excitement as if it came as if it as
if it every time it turns it wants to
make an allusion to another kind of text
as if it feels itself in some sense with
a kind of excitement and exuberant
energy constantly in touch with its
ancestry and with an ancestry that it
tries to define very generously and
broadly and well so what we're saying is
that formally structurally the film is
the film is expressing a special kind of
intellectual energy excitement
exuberance right and and of course
what's interesting and fundamental about
that is that those energies are also
replicated centrally re-enacted in the
actual dance sequences that we see in
them in the in the in the film it's a
profoundly rich example of what I called
a moment ago organic form the structure
or the shape of the film contributes to
our sense not only that it has a kind of
encyclopedic self reflexive interest in
its own history and that it's
recapitulating its own history for us as
it as it proceeds we also have a deep
sense a deep sense of the extent to
which the film understands that many of
the older forms that dramatizes are now
simply being archived as if the film
understands itself not only as a as a
dramatic as a dramatic entertainment but
also as a kind of history book or a kind
of encyclopedia literally a kind of
archive of all the forms of performance
and song and dance that lie behind the
making of such of such a film and of
course that this formal exuberance as I
said is repeated again and again in a in
an actual eyes than concrete way in the
story in the plot every time the
character starts singing or dancing and
as you'll see there's a particular kind
of exuberance and energy in many of the
dances key themes well I've already
implicitly been talking about some of
the themes but let me mention just two
that are seem to me
especially significant a significant one
I've mentioned much earlier and I'd
simply want to remind you again that
this tension between what might be
called high art and the pretentious
expectations of a cultural establishment
are set up for parody and mockery in
this film repeatedly the film is on the
side of the of the of the popular and
the energetic and the exam and the
unpretentious and and and and one can
feel that tension again and again in
many many of the sequences in the movie
in the in the film just one object me
give you just two obvious examples one
in the very opening sequence of the film
one of the classic moments in the
history of American movies we played
again and again in in compilation
anthologies of the great of great
moments in in Hollywood great moments of
Hollywood film is the introduction to
the film and the introduction to singing
in the rain recreates a historical
actuality that I need to remind today's
audiences of shows you how old this
course is because when I first began to
teach this course these practices were
still going on and the students still
still understood and in fact had their
own experience of exhibition movies in a
way that most of and of and of going to
theaters that that were very lavish and
and and and in many ways even even
pretentious and what they were
especially aware of is something I have
to remind you of now which is that very
often Hollywood had a strategy of
rolling out its great blockbuster what
it hoped would be great blockbuster
films with very elaborate inaugural
events right the debut of a film was
often a major event and it would be
covered by newspapers and and many
Hollywood stars would be covered would
come and attend and they would turn they
would turn the event into a publicity
event partly in order to get publicity
for the for the release of the film
right and singing in the rain opens with
it with such a moment in which a film is
opening and and it dramatizes the the
the the comic hypocrisy is that attend
such such
city gestures and as the film opens then
we have a simile we see a sequence in
which the star of the the stars of the
of the film were about to see Gene Kelly
is interviewed the star of the film is
interviewed by a reporter and he then
tells sort of the story of his of his
career but the story of that he tells is
fake is a lie it's very pretentious all
we went to the best conservatories we
were trained by classical musicians and
classical actors actors right and he
acts very pretend but what that's what
he says but what we see when is shown to
us is the actual history of how Don
Lockwood and his partner his sidekick
are played by the brilliant performer
Donald O'Connor really got their start
and so the while he says we were trained
in the best conservatories what we see
are Donald O'Connor and Gene Kelly
dancing in a burlesque show and and so
the so that there's this there's a
constant very obvious even in some ways
crude mockery or laughter at the
hypocrisy 's of hollywood and part of
what's being celebrated there is the
exuberance and energy of unsanctioned
forms of performance like the dances
that people do in burlesque shows right
as against what you do when you go to
the museum or when you come to the
university and have your professor
declaim ancient Greek to you in
syllables you have no understanding of
right so so there's one example of how
that theme plays out but you can find it
in dozens and dozens of other places in
the film and I hope you'll watch watch
for them well it's for such moments oh
so I won't give you my second example
I'm running out of time oh let me turn
to a next to the next large theme I want
you to be aware of I call it the theme
of outer versus inner it's really a
variation on or an extension of the
theme of high versus popular art in the
sense that it's also about the
difference between a kind of pretentious
and constraining and old-fashioned view
of things and a more spontaneous and and
and I we might even
a more spontaneous and popular or
democratic view of things this when I
saw and the term I give it is the
difference between outer and inner or
the difference between appearance and
reality and in in fact the example I
just gave you in which we have Don
Lockwood telling the reporter that he
was educated in the best conservatories
while we see that he's dancing in a
burlesque show is an example of that
kind of thing as well but there are many
other very dramatic examples and I want
to mention one of them now the the when
when when the Debbie Reynolds character
the love interest of the of our
protagonist first meets the Don Lockwood
character with character played by Gene
Kelly she pretends not to recognize him
even though he's a famous movie star and
she says ooh and she says and and she
says old she spends her time watching
Shakespeare but she doesn't spend much
time watching the movies and Don
Lockwood is kind of offended by this it
later turns out not even that much later
that of course did the Debbie Reynolds
character herself is deeply immersed in
the popular culture right after she
makes this comment to Don Lockwood a few
a few minutes after that we find her
jumping out of a cake as a dancer in a
in a at a party and and and and what we
work in and then as more information
emerges later we come to recognize of
course that that of course she knows a
great deal about Don Lockwood she's
always been a tremendous fan of the
movies but she's been covering it up and
again and again in the in the film we
see this kind of tension playing itself
out this tension between a kind of outer
facade a kind of a kind of and the
notion is that what is shown on the
outside what the exterior of things is
often fake a mere a mere cover for what
is authentic and within right and you
can understand this in the number of
ways but if you think one of the ways it
plays out in the movie is the question
of the person who is who's in front of
the audience and singing but it's not
really her voice it's the voice of
Debbie Reynolds who's behind the curtain
right and that so that so that again
this theme of of the artificial versus
the authentic or the outer versus the
inner plays itself out in many many ways
in the film that's
what makes the film so coherent so so so
so dramatically effective and energetic
and so another way of thinking about
this sequence this idea of the outer
versus the outer person versus the inner
authentic person the the outer
appearance the illusion that film makes
but what really goes on behind the
scenes and as you'll discover singing in
the rain constantly takes us behind the
scenes to show us how the illusion of
movies is put together right and that's
a part of this same theme so one of the
things I'm trying to call your attention
to again is the way in which the be the
central ideas of the film permeate both
its form and its content in ways that
make it very difficult to separate right
finally one last fundamental issue
connected to what I've been saying
before the way the film meditates on or
dramatizes an idea about the place of
song and dance in human life you will
have noticed of course that I myself
feel and if you've seen any of the
performances in this film you'll know
yourselves that a principle of energy
vitality playfulness exuberance is
almost always present in the dances in
singin in the rain song and dance is
seen in singin in the rain as a morally
and psychologically revolutionary
experience I think and I use the word
revolution in a dangerous way I don't
mean a politically revolutionary way but
I mean in a morally a psychologically
revolutionary way and over what so
what's going on in some sense is the
sense that constraint and convention are
constantly threatened by the exuberant
spontaneity energy excitement vitality
of the dance right and this expresses
itself in all kinds of ways in the film
let me just mention a couple to call
your attention to this you'll discover
many many other examples one is the
wonderful sequence the Moses supposes
sequence this is a sequence in which Don
Lockwood and his partner Donald O'Connor
have to be trained because they're
making the transition to sound and the
studio calls in an elocution expert
who's a very who's dressed up like a
very pretentious
old line professor right and he's going
to teach them how to pronounce things
correctly so he comes in and and he says
I want you to repeat after me
Moses supposes his toeses are roses but
Moses supposes erroneously right he's
also ugly as teeth are disgusting
you're already offended by the guy
before dawn and his comrade begin to
respond but and also of course what's
ridiculous about this it's meaningless
talk right or he's so interested in
making him pronounce the the old vowel
properly that he creates meaning
meaningless sentences but but their
meaninglessness amuses Don Lockwood and
his partner and what they did
essentially what they do is they take
the Moses supposes lines and they begin
to sort of make fun of them and they
begin to make fun of their of their
interlocutor their teacher they end up
taking a garbage can and emptying it out
it's just as paper putting it on his
head they end up dancing in a ridiculous
way so they end up dancing on top of
desks or up the side of walls again what
are they doing their dances are
violating the normal spaces in which we
expect people to be walking or standing
upright the very way in which the dance
violates normal boundaries creates this
sense of exuberance and a freedom so
what they're doing is they're rebelling
against the pretentiousness on the
constraints of these of this kind of
this kind of high culture expectation
and and the song and dance in the Moses
supposes sequence create a kind of
exuberant chaos in which they dance on
the tables and make fun of the very
elements that they're supposed to be
learning the good morning sequence one
of the great sequences in the history of
movies I think shows the same thing but
it takes place at breakfast in an
ordinary domestic space which is
transfigured or transformed including
the props in something of that we might
imagine Chaplin doing such imaginative
things in which in which the ordinary
props of the kitchen turn become
partners in the dance become elements in
a dance what we feel is the imaginative
power of love and an end of performance
transforming an ordinary space and we
can see this principle operating in with
an even greater force in the title
sequence of the film probably the most
famous sequence of
in the in in the history of Hollywood
the singin in the rain sequence itself
we see the rain itself what a funny
place to be dancing right there's a
contradiction but your exuberance your
energy your sense of love is so great
that even rain doesn't matter and watch
what happens he has an umbrella but he
doesn't use the umbrella to protect him
from the rain
violating our expectation there's a one
wonderful moment in the film where he
hands the umbrella in the midst of
pouring rain to someone else who goes by
to a pedestrian who goes by right
there's a moment when he's dancing in
the rain he take puts the umbrella down
the rains come but he doesn't have
enough rain pouring on him he steps
under a downspout to have them even more
rain come down and when we experience
this what we feel is not what one of the
reasons we experienced this as joyful
and as assertive and as individualizing
is the sense we have that these are
exactly not things that people normally
do he's over going or violating certain
conventions or literal boundaries and
there's one moment in their dance very
dramatic I know this incidentally not
because I've discovered it myself but
because 20 years ago or 15 years ago in
this course a student who later went on
to work in Hollywood and he still works
there is a sound genius he was an MIT
engineer who loved this course and was a
musician as well he wrote a paper for me
about that sequence and he showed me
this and I'm sure that some smart
critics also saw it but I learned this
from an MIT student in this course about
15 years ago he analyzed the dance
sequence very closely and one of the
things he showed was that the decisive
moment in the dance occurs when the or a
decisive moment in the dance occurs when
the kelie character suddenly is dancing
on the sidewalk jumps off the sidewalk
across the curb into the street and
psychologically it has a tremendously
profound effect because you don't walk
in the street much less dance in the
street the streets for this the street
is for cars but that violation of the
boundary expresses the sense of
exuberance of freedom that is supposed
to be pressed that is that is the that
is the the essential meaning of what
these dances represent so energy
spontaneous feeling performing and over
going limits is one of the things that's
being expressed in
in the in the exuberance of the films
formal structure in its encyclopedic
reaching out to other forms which it
wants to incorporate into itself and in
its particular dance and song sequences
and this energy this celebration of
transformative energy of the over going
of boundaries strikes me as particularly
American as a tree as a uniquely
interesting expression of what people
have sometimes called American optimism
and even of the democratic spirit of the
openness that we associate with
Democratic that we associate with our
ideals not the reality but our ideals of
democratic society what these dances and
songs tell us then about the place of
dance and song in our lives the idea
that you would begin to dance in a space
unused to dance hostel to dance
transforms the space right so what this
film then says about these things is
that our speech can be nudged into song
our way of walking can be edged into a
dance and that the ordinary objects in
our domestic and public spaces can
become props can become props in an
improvised valet when we turn to Cabaret
we're looking at a very different kind
of object and it's important to
recognize what I mentioned earlier and I
will develop more fully in a couple of
weeks the fact that now we have gone
almost beyond genre there are people who
would argue and there are purists of the
music scholars of the musical film who
want to argue that well cabaret really
isn't a musical for a variety of reasons
it seems to be a very strange and
unhelpful argument but I think if you
watch the film closely you'll understand
why people who are partisans of the
great Hollywood musical tradition or
even the older operetta tradition
represented by by directors like Rouben
Mamoulian would have problems fitting
cabaret into the category of musical I
think it's a misunderstanding of how we
should think about musicals but for the
moment let's just let me just encourage
you to watch the film and think about
how different it is from traditional
musicals and especially its tone its
it's moral perspective but but also it's
it's it's in its structure think about
that and you'll understand more fully
why it's easy to see that this film
could not would not have would be very
unlikely to have been made in the
Hollywood era that it required the kind
of freedom that came to film after film
was no longer constrained by the
necessity to speak to a in a consensus
voice and as I said these are matters I
will try to clarify and conclude with
one in two weeks when I returned to this
question when we talk about film in the
70s and the great seventies Western
almost contemporary with Cabaret Robert
Altman's McCabe and mrs. Miller I had
hoped to say a number of things about
falsies career but I don't have time and
I'm just going to encourage you look him
up he's a very very remarkable figure in
some psyche all him the inheritor
because he began his career in
connection but he began he was both a
Broadway director and choreographer and
a dancer both on Broadway and in films
and he performed and directed both on
Broadway and in films he was a first a
choreographer and films before he became
a director and in this career as a
performer and choreographer he linked up
with almost all the other great names of
the American musical stage both the
Broadway stage and the Hollywood
tradition and in that sense we can say
that that that Bob Fosse is the
inheritor of the great tradition of a
matter of the American Musical and I
wish I could go into detail about this
and show you how many filiation 's and
specific connections he has with the
great figures of the Classical Age of
American movies and especially the
Classical Age of the of the American
musical but suffice it to say that it's
a very rich set of connections and his
career is a very remarkable career a
very very honored career let me mention
one fact about his career perhaps most
the most remarkable one easy-to-remember
tells you something about his his
diversity has as a director his gifts
his ambition in 1973 Bob Fosse I think
became the only man in history to win an
Oscar a Tony and an Emmy an Oscar for
for cabaret as Best Director and a Tony
for at best or maybe he'd won as Best
Director or hit the play that he
directed on Broadway Pippin won as Best
Play on Broadway and he also won a
television Emmy for a show starring Liza
Minnelli the star in cabaret called Liza
with a Z so and I think he's the only
man in history for whom those three
awards came in the in the same year for
three different for three different
texts he directed one two three four
five films of which of cabaret was the
second they are all all well the last
four are all very remarkable and
interesting texts I I won't talk about
them here except to encourage you to
look him up and think about them the
theme of performance and the idea of the
characters who are characters who are
themselves performer performers are
always at the center of his films even
film not because not all of his films
involve Dancy but he made a film about
the life of Lenny Bruce called Lenny
starring Dustin Hoffman for example that
doesn't have musical numbers in it but
it has many performance numbers in it
and it's a very rich complex
sophisticated film so for an interesting
and and and profoundly serious director
I wish I could say more about his career
I want to say a word about the context
of cabaret so you'll understand that
aspect of the film more fully - it said
in vimar Germany that curious time in
the 1920s before the during the rise of
Nazism but before Hitler has come long
before Hitler has come to power but in
which the the Vimal Republic are
vulnerable and and and unstable
democracy but but a democracy in which
an enormous amount of the artistic
literary experimentation was taking
place it's the period of German
Expressionism it's the period of the
great German silent films that we talked
about earlier and so our film cabaret is
set in that era and in that driven era
in in that divided era in which the rise
of Nazism was coupled with was or joined
to and connected to the the the fact
that German society was what was was
under immense constraints because it had
lost the first world war the conditions
under which they had been forced to
surrender were very onerous there was
very high levels of unemployment it was
a it was a society it was a
schizophrenic Lee designed divide in
society a society of great artistic
energies but of great political
divisions and and and difficulties and
and nightmare possibilities that were
lurking in it's in it in in in many of
its practices and there's a link or at
least a partial link between the
instability and the excitement but also
the divided nosov vimar germany and the
actual condition of the united states in
the era when the movie came out right
because this is the period at the end of
the 60s after the late 60s and early 70s
probably the most divided time in
American history after the Second World
War before our current moment right and
in fact the divisions then were more
legitimate that is to buy more
legitimate I mean they they had a more
sensible cause there was a tear there
were terrible Wars going on there were
there were there were there were better
reasons for them for the partisanship
that occurred in the 1960s and early 70s
than there are for the weird
partisanship were suffering in the
United States in the United States today
and and in any case there was a much
greater sense in the late 60s and early
70s that the fabric of American society
was under attack that it was imperfect
not only because the Vietnam War and so
divided the country against itself but
because of other other matters as well
including the increasing militancy of of
the civil rights movement which had
which had which had gone from a sort of
Martin Luther King type
commitment to to to a nonviolent protest
into into much more disturbing in some
and sometimes violent confrontations
with authorities and with some theorists
and speakers actually calling for for
violence and this racial tension was
then coupled by another kind of
political tension coming from the people
from the young men and women who were
mostly young men and women who were
opposed to the Vietnam War
so it was a very driven and disturbed
they were then parallels between the
instability and the disturbance of the
VY Mar period and the period in which
the film appeared and the original
audiences I think would have been highly
aware of this of this connection would
have seen that although the film was set
in the past it spoke to the contemporary
moment in a very powerful way I want to
also remind you that that there are
certain aspects there are certain
aspects of the style of of Cabaret that
are worth keeping in mind and one way to
think about this is to recognize that
both Misa and sin style and montage
style remember are are are embody don't
act in the film and and and are carried
to extremes in certain moments of the
film that is to say in many of the
performance sequences in the film the
camera behaves in an unbelievably
frenetic and frantic way changes your
eye angle jumps around a lot does this
disorients you sometime almost
disorients you in the style of a
Hitchcock and yet in other sequences in
the film especially those outside the
Cabaret that take place in ordinary life
not in a performance space like the
camera and the editing slowed down and
become more like a kind of meson sense
style and the combination of the two is
especially rich and interesting you
might want to watch for the way these
rhythms alter your sense of what's
happening in the film well the way the
film slows down and speeds up at certain
point and I mean I I mean this literally
in terms of the number of images that go
by quickly but also in terms of the way
the physical bodies of the performers
move across the screen and of course the
way in which the camera itself behaves
whether it's jittery and movement or or
oriented toward constant movement or
whether it's more stable and gives you a
chance to look at the environment your
your this scene is set in one way I can
give you a sense of the richness of the
film is to remind you that there's a
kind of texture or multiplicity in
cabaret in almost every moment that if
you watch for it and you're attentive to
it you will always be rewarded let me
just give you two very quick examples of
what I mean by this remember I suggested
to you that this principle of
multiplicity is one of the principles we
turn to if we want to recognize a work
of art right the difference between a
work of art and an entertainment in my
terms is that in a work of art is just
more intelligent that is to say it makes
more complex use of its materials so
that in a entertainment a particular
event or gesture may have only one
function but in a work of art you will
have multiple functions it will perform
several jobs simultaneously and if you
I'll give you two examples of this um
think about what takes place on the
periphery of what you're watching and
you'll begin to get some sense of one
way in which the texture of this film
come brings the material alive there's
one moment I think fairly early in the
film it's a street scene we're not
paying much attention to what's going on
we see we see I think the the
protagonists walking in the street and
around on the periphery of the Mora or
or sort of not certainly not in the
center of the frame nothing that is
commented on by the characters a [ __ ]
slides by on one of those wheeled
platforms that people without legs
sometimes used in major cities before
but maybe they still happen but they're
but but but they're but but they were
very common in in the first half of the
20th century and we see this guy who's
obviously is a wounded veteran and he's
he's a he's an amputee
and he pushes himself along on this card
and and we just see him go by but what's
interesting about that is that he's this
[ __ ] on the platform has a little
flag on his platform guess what kind of
a flag it is it's a Nazi flag right and
this is early in the film before the
Nazis have become a powerful for the
rise of Nazism is in the background
as you'll see come the Nazis moved from
the periphery to the center of the frame
before the film is over and that's the
fundamental historical motion of the
film but all of that's taking place in
the background the foreground are the
central characters and the the comic and
innocent and and ultimately not so comic
disturbing love affairs and difficulties
that they encounter in this environment
would be they're too naive or innocent
to understand the historical forces that
are surrounding them so that example of
the Nazi flag and this crippled figure
because the crippled figure is in fact
an allusion to the onerous demands that
were put upon Germany because by France
and the other allies at the end of the
war and this [ __ ] is in some sense
this crippled so the assumption is he's
probably a war veteran I don't remember
if he's actually wearing the uniform
which would confirm this and it would be
helpful if he would but I don't remember
watch for it and you'll see but in any
case he refers to that and anyone
attentive to the film can recognize that
the historical texture of the of the
film is is carried by such moments
there's another such moment also so
minor that you might not notice it if
the foreground is the love affair what
Laurie did not yet a love affair but the
acquaintance the deepening friendship
between the two protagonists Sally
Bowles and her boyfriend
and they go what they go out for a walk
in Berlin and Sally pretends that she is
this immensely sophisticated woman turns
out that she's fooling herself and
fooling us she's not at all even though
she pretends to a great kind of
sophistication and she sings dirty songs
in a cabaret and she performs in a
cabaret where they make jokes about
everything including all forms of sexual
perversion nonetheless she's an innocent
she has no way of recognizing the depth
and complexity of the evil that's built
the moral evil and moral terror that's
building around her and she's not alone
in this most of the other characters in
the foreground of the film perform this
same naive ballet although Sally Bowles
is the most powerful instance of it it
is certainly Liza Minelli's greatest
role certainly the role that you'll be
remembered for long
she's dead long after we're all in the
in the ground Liza Minelli's performance
in this film will still be treasured and
savored I think um so another instance
of the multiplicity when when when we
find the two two characters are walking
in the street and Sally says oh I want
to show you something I do and she pulls
this guy along she leans up against the
side of an elevated train stanchion
right and she waits until the train
comes by and as the train comes by she
screams and she says say man if you wait
for the noise nobody will hear you
scream and she's just expressing her
exuberance showing her she's showing him
how she commands this space how she
knows how to use this urban space right
but there's an irony she's unaware of
when she leans up against the wall
behind her what we see are political
posters and the political posters behind
her are defaced they're both Nazi and
communist posters and the Communists and
the Nazis are defacing one another's
posters and what is implicit then again
in the background against the against
the foreground of these of these two
relatively naive characters carrying on
is the historical reality that's
building behind them another example of
what I mean by the multiplicity the
texture of this film right finally the
music next to finally the musical
numbers penultimately the musical
numbers another kind of integration is
going on in this film right when we talk
about the integrated musical as Earth
they're freed and his comrades during
the studio era articulated this idea
we're not talking about the form of
integration that we see in cabaret and
this in fact is one of the reasons that
some people argue that cabaret is not a
musical because with one exception
none of the musical performances in
cabaret take place out of a performance
environment they all take place in the
Cabaret the film is about a cabaret
performer and we see many performances
in the Cabaret now when we watch those
performances we see them from angles
that no one in the audience could ever
see because Fosse is a genius with the
camera and creates visual effects
drawing on the tradition of the
Hollywood musical that could never be
replicated in a theatre nonetheless
the performances themselves are
theatrical performances they all are
real performances and when we see the
characters behaving like real characters
they don't suddenly burst into song and
dance okay because there's something
theoretically so implausible about that
that cabaret refuses that convention
right it refuses to embrace that basic
convention of the American Musical which
is that one way that people express
their exuberance I love you
I love you now let me sing a song
telling you how much I love you right
whereas in real life we don't do that
now I don't think that this convention
is really a bad canal is a convention
that undermines the music it's like
convention or a rule or a habit a
protocol you need to embrace in order to
experience these films appropriately and
it's no more implausible in one sense
than the implausibility of opera singers
bursting into song at moments of great
passion right it's the the convention
requires it it's as if it's as if we're
in a form of artistic experience in
which in which art is crystallizing
experience for us so I don't mean to
undermine this convention at all or cast
doubt on it but cabaret refuses that
convention cabaret says every time with
one exception there I'm calling
attention to that exception I'm not
going to tell you what it is but I want
you to watch for it there's one moment
in the film when there is a song sung
outside by ordinary people it happens
spontaneously it may be the most morally
and historically frightening moment in
the whole of the film and it's
completely believable just as this
employ totally plausible that it would
happen but that's the only moment in the
film when there's any singing that
doesn't take place inside a space
intended for singing and dancing so one
of the interesting things about cabaret
is that there is a kind of true
integration of song and dance because
none of that happens except in spaces
where it's appropriate right
realistically appropriate right and so
you might watch for that and and the the
the complexity that this decision on the
part of Bob Fosse and the people making
the film the the the impact of that of
that decision on your understanding of
the movie as a whole finally the central
themes of the film I've already talked
about them the theme of innocence the
way the central characters in the film
are too innocent to understand the
historical forces around them
underestimate this isn't just true of
the sense
figures it's true of the secondary
characters as well some of whom are even
more poignant Lee more weeks or even
more poignant Lee embody this theme and
then the theme of history what history
is one how how the power how the force
of history can overwhelm individual
desires individual oops love itself and
of course also the limits of satire the
Cabaret is a space of satire space of
mockery a space of exuberant
intellectual distance and disdain much
of the energy of the Cabaret comes from
an impulse of parody mockery satire
right and in the very beginning of the
film there's actually a moment where you
can see the Joel Grey character who
plays this arm in a strange figure of
the MC the interlocutor right in the
Cabaret he sort of is the is the master
of ceremonies and there's one moment
early in the film when he when he in a
rather disgusting scene in which they
have a sort of they replicate a scene of
mud wrestling and and he's emceeing it
and he reaches down he picks up a piece
of one he rubs it on his upper lip and
he makes himself look like Hitler and
he's mocking Hitler and then right well
if you compare that early moment in
which Hitler and Nazism are objects of
mockery there's also an early scene in
which we see a Nazi being pulled out of
the audience of the Cabaret and pushed
outside right kicked out of the Cabaret
because Nazis are thought to be
unacceptable there's ought to be
vulgarians right this is early and by
the time the film is over by the but by
the time you come to the very end of the
film one of the very final images of the
film shows us the audience of the
Cabaret filled with Nazi officers filled
with Nazi uniforms the Nazis have moved
from the periphery to the center of the
movie and that's part of the terror and
that the film dramatizes and it also
therefore of course dramatizes the
limits of satire because the Cabaret
itself like the characters imagines
itself to be exempted from or apart from
history it can maintain its mockery it's
distance satire can protect me from all
the and of course the Cabaret is just as
naive as the characters themselves
it's overwhelmed by the forces of his
three in a way in a way that the
characters themselves also are both of
these films in their own way have
generated a tremendously interesting and
serious volume of discourse both in
terms of their musical qualities and the
qualities of their of their choreography
and in terms of their content they're
really such complex films that watching
them together makes an immense
intellectual demand on everyone I know
you're capable of that but I hope that
you will take the time to let the
implications of these films settle into
your mind for days and maybe even weeks
after you've watched them and I hope of
course that this first viewing will only
be the first of many I wish you the joy
of these wonderful movies
you